so let's give this guy a go
symmetry factorize asymptotes intercepts
regions i'll save you some time i will
tell you this graph has no symmetry okay
you can slap in minus x and it gives you
nothing right it's not very polite to
you okay so there's no symmetric
symmetry we can take advantage of no
obvious one anyway
i'll save you some more time you can't
factorize it okay
both of these guys have no solutions
they both have no solutions the
numerator in the denominator if you let
them equal zero you won't get any real
numbers out of that okay we get complex
numbers but that's another topic
so because i have no symmetry i have no
i have no factorization um that by the
way
kind of answers the last question for
you already right in terms of regions in
terms of regions
this guy is always positive and this guy
is always positive so therefore the
quotient of those will also be always
positive okay so in regions it's a bit
boring okay
now let's think about the asymptotes
okay
um
vertical asymptotes because the
denominator never equals zero because
you can't factorize it there's no
vertical asymptote so that's nice okay
now let's think about the horizontal or
oblique asymptote that you would get out
of this thing okay
the degree of these two parts right are
the same x squared divided by x squared
so as i approach infinity okay both
positive and negative okay these fours
how important are they
not important they just disappear away
these x's they're kind of important but
they're not important when you compare
them to the x squares right no matter
how enormous these guys get the squares
will always be more important and that's
kind of why we look at the degree the
highest power is what takes over okay
so they're the same
if i say okay x equals a thousand this
guy will be a million
and this guy will also be a million so a
million and a little bit divided by a
million and a little bit will basically
be
one
right it'll be one okay
let's be a little more fine
and we say as x approaches infinity
okay
y is approaching we've just said one
is it coming from the top or the bottom
the way you can know is again like we
can do this analytically but let's just
try it out with a number okay um
a thousand very large let's just do a
hundred okay what's this going to be 100
scared is
10 000.
that's what i meant to say 10 000 uh
minus i put in 100 didn't i so this will
be 200 plus four
okay on the denominator it's the same
thing just i have a plus in the middle
10 000
plus 200 plus 4. now don't calculate
anything just tell me which number
numerator denominator which one's bigger
the bottom is bigger right so if you
have numbers where the denominator is
bigger like four fifths or seven eighths
or 999
over ten thousand are you above or below
one and the answer is you are below you
are below okay so therefore i'm
approaching it from below
and uh
because of how similar the numerator and
denominator are you can see when i put
in minus infinity i'm just going to do
the other thing
okay i'm just gonna do the other thing
i'm approaching from the top
so i've got an asymptote let's put this
guy in
y equals one
y equals one there he is
y equals one
i know i'm going to be approaching
from the bottom
over here okay and i'm going to be
approaching
from the top
over here that's all i know so far
okay
symmetry i've factorized i've worked out
all the asymptotes there's only one okay
intercepts all right let's give it a go
intercepts now before i do anything
before i do anything
uh you can see right like if i if i
don't have a solution to this
and i don't have a solution to this
right
there are no there are no x intercepts
there'll be no x inside but i can put in
x equals zero that'll give me a y
intercept right
when you put in x equals zero zero zero
zero zero one you have four over four
which is what
wait
it's not okay
so
it's a it's a horizontal asymptote
so it only tells me about the
extremities so can i cross it of course
i can i have no problem crossing a
horizontal or oblique asymptote
all right
i've gone through my whole process you
remember i didn't draw regions on do you
remember why i didn't draw regions on
it's all positive okay so let's think
about what this thing must do let's
think about what things do
i know i'm approaching from the bottom
and i've got to come from here i'm going
to come from here okay so could i do
this
nope because i'm going to have to
approach from the top if that's the case
okay or i'm going to have to wiggle more
times and there just there aren't enough
powers to get that number of of changes
okay so no i'm not going to approach i'm
not going to go up first
i'm going to go down i'm going to go
down i'm going to do something like this
what else can it do it has to go down it
can't touch the axis because it can
never go negative and it can never even
have an x intercept there's no solutions
there right and so i have to come back
up before i get there and approach my
asymptote just like you expected
okay
on the left hand side
you're going to get much the same thing
right he can't go down because remember
it has to be smooth right so if it's
it's sort of going doing this right and
so it's going to be approaching like
that
there's the graph
now i could stop i could go home
you've done you've gone through
everything you don't know calculus
and differentiation which i've alluded
to before right so therefore strictly
speaking
these points here like how high does it
go how low does it go we don't really
know okay so at this point i would be
happy to to just say the question is
finished okay
however however oh yeah we do need some
points for scale okay
however i am going to press on this a
little further because actually we don't
need calculus to find these two spots
and the reason why i'm going to address
this is because
it addresses something we already know
okay so i'm going to push into something
a little bit more advanced so we can
take on a harder question and answer
something you've already been asked
about domain and range by the way domain
and range it is accessible okay you'll
get it with much easier functions but
there's no reason we can't do it with
this okay
so here we go this is the hardest part
of what we're about to do but if you can
hang on to your hats you'll see
something quite i think it's quite
mathematically beautiful we can do this
and not need some really really hard
math
first question what's the domain is this
part
what's the domain all real values i can
go everywhere
all good okay
what about range what about range
clearly i'm restricted in somewhere
right so it's going to be like y right
has got to be greater than something and
less than something but the question is
what are those
like
can i find out what they are if i find
out what they are then i have these
positions right because that's the
highest spot and then my range is below
that and here's the lowest spot and my
range is above that does that make sense
okay so how do i do this right